a symbolic moment in the capital
Croatia's prime minister and the
European commission president paying for
their coffee in euros
the first day of the new year has come
with two more firsts adopting the Euro
and joining the Border free Schengen
Zone earlier at the border with Slovenia
the two leaders had this to say
if there are historical moments special
moments which should provide us with
great honor and when we witness the
achievement of strategic goals of a
state this is such a day
being able to cross internal borders
without controls is one important
achievement
being able to pay cross-borders using
the same EU currency is another one
and I know by my own personal experience
that croatians will always remember the
first time they paid with euros
the first time they held the Euro coin
minted with your national emblem the
Kuna but it's not that simple for many
people for the next few weeks you can
still pay in the old currency the kuna
but the change must now be given in
euros and that's causing confusion
this buyer tells us she has two wallets
now
convert the chain she loves I still
don't know we are showing the app they
use to calculate the change
we have this app now so converting is
more or less simple Creations are still
paying in kunas and foreigners are
paying in Euros we love the kuna more of
course because it's our currency
I'm not happy about the Euro but it's
not a problem for me to convert I have
some kuna and small euros and the rest I
will take from the cash machine if it
will work it's total chaos with the ATMs
it will be an adjustment for everyone
and it will take time as the newest
member of the European Union Croatia is
the 20th country to adopt the Euro and
go through this transition there is no
doubt there will be challenges over the
next couple of weeks as croatians let go
of their currency and gradually go fully
Euro Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera Zagreb